Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Alla parola "scuola"
è molto probabile che immaginiamo questo.
Cioè un edificio,
con bambini e bambine più o meno felici.
Se dicessi "scuola secondaria",
già magari immagineremmo qualcos'altro.
Però, la costante è l'edificio:
nell'immaginazione comune,
la scuola è un edificio.
In realtà, la pandemia
ci ha insegnato che non è così:
perché gli edifici erano chiusi,
ma le scuole erano aperte.
E improvvisamente,
sembrava che si scatenasse
la creatività, la fantasia.
Stavamo iniziando a sconfinare:
aule all'aperto,
solidarietà con i genitori.
Ma non appena la pandemia si è chiusa,
o l'emergenza si è chiusa,
siamo tornati a immaginare
la scuola come un edificio,
e quindi a rinchiuderci nelle scuole.
Questo perché la nostra scuola,
e la scuola dei nostri padri,
la scuola dei nostri nonni,
è un'immagine fissa.
Noi ci immaginiamo la scuola
come un edificio;
e a noi umani, a volte,
serve avere degli automatismi,
delle immagini fisse
perché ci aiutano a salvaguardare energia.
Però, anche, non ci permettono
di guardare oltre.
Per cui, come prima cosa da fare
abbiamo bisogno di sconfinare
con i nostri schemi mentali, per cambiare.
E quindi, io cercherò di accompagnarvi
in una sorta di percorso,
una "mappa di sconfinamento"
dove andremo a vedere quelli che sono
gli schemi mentali sulla scuola,
e le chiavi per sconfinare.
Seguendo il pensiero, l'esperienza
di un nutrito gruppo di persone
di cui sono parte,
che stanno sostenendo
una rivoluzione educativa,
la trasformazione educativa.
Sono persone di provenienza
geografica diversa,
ma anche di ambiti diversi.
Ecco: iniziamo con il primo
schema mentale,
e poi la prima chiave.
Vediamo il primo: a scuola
non si può essere felici.
Abbiamo come un immaginario:
ai ragazzi e alle ragazze
non piace la scuola.
In realtà, neanche a noi adulti piace;
ed è un po' come un male necessario.
Ma non è sempre così.
La nostra chiave è la partecipazione.
È possibile essere felici.
Una volta, in una classe,
ero con le maestre,
le bambine e i bambini,
e stavamo coprogettando
la piazza che è di fianco alla scuola.
E Greta, nove anni, mi dice:
"Quando faccio queste cose
io mi sento troppo bene.
Io mi sento troppo felice: mi sento viva!"
Ecco: Greta, con una frase,
ci fa comprendere che si può vivere
la scuola diversamente.
E, anche, conferma i dati
dell'Organizzazione Mondiale della Sanità,
sono dati del 2006,
che dicono che, laddove i ragazzi
e le ragazze partecipano,
si sentono partecipi del cambiamento,
diminuisce la delinquenza,
diminuisce l'uso di sostanze,
diminuisce l'abbandono scolastico -
sapete che abbiamo punte, in Italia,
anche del 34% - e aumenta il benessere.
Quindi significa salute:
la partecipazione significa salute,
perché la salute non è solo
assenza di malattie.
E inoltre, partecipare significa
partecipare dei processi decisionali
che riguardano i ragazzi e le ragazze,
essere ascoltati;
e significa avere esperienza
diretta della democrazia,
cosa che non è da poco.
Se questo è la nostra prima chiave,
una delle più importanti,
possiamo passare a quella che è il luogo.
Allora, le scuole sono brutte.
Non è che devo dirvelo:
le scuole sono brutte.
Però, lo schema mentale è che non importa,
perché ciò che importa
è imparare a leggere e scrivere.
Non è vero:
gli spazi non sono neutri,
gli spazi insegnano.
Ed è per questo che noi parliamo
di "spazi pedagogici".
E qui mi faccio aiutare
da un'altra ragazzina,
questa volta di Napoli, di undici anni.
Durante un incontro, lei dice:
"Io quando vedo i banchi,
uno dietro l'altro,
non mi permettono di guardarmi intorno,
mi fanno guardare in un'unica direzione."
Ecco: è geniale,
perché passa da quello che è
lo schema della classe, dello spazio,
a quello che è uno schema
di pensiero, unidirezionale.
Possiamo vederlo anche qui oggi, no?
Io sono qui, voi siete dall'altra parte.
Se io guardo la signora intensamente,
il signore che è dietro
non può vedere che faccia sta facendo,
non può far muovere quei neuroni specchio
che gli permetterebbero di avere empatia,
di relazionarsi con la signora.
Però oggi va bene,
questo spazio forma è adeguato.
Non dobbiamo costruire una comunità,
non dobbiamo neanche
stare insieme cinque anni,
come succede nelle scuole.
Quindi oggi va bene: ma nelle scuole
questo, invece, è fondamentale.
Se noi abbiamo dei dei banchi direzionati
verso un'unica persona,
delle sedie isolate
significa che stiamo portando un pensiero,
un pensiero unidirezionale,
un pensiero individualista.
E per questo lo spazio non può -
ha bisogno di essere modificato.
E inoltre, se noi scartiamo
e saltiamo su questo schema mentale,
possiamo capire che anche la città
può essere una grande aula
di apprendimento
perché si apprende in contesti
formali e informali.
E sull'apprendimento, anche,
passa quello che è un altro schema.
Ecco: "Si apprende se alunni e alunne
stanno zitti e ascoltano".
Anche questo non è vero.
Cioè, succede: ma non è sempre vero.
Le maestre lo sanno benissimo,
sono stati scritti fiumi di inchiostro:
è necessaria una didattica attiva.
I bambini e le bambine,
ma anche i ragazzi e le ragazze,
hanno bisogno di sperimentare,
di ricercare, di toccare con mano.
Hanno bisogno di usare il loro corpo.
E per esempio, una cosa
è sentir parlare della lettera i
e una cosa è sentire
con il corpo la lettera i,
come stanno facendo
questi bambini e queste bambine
della prima B di una scuola primaria.
E che cosa succede?
Che l'insegnante ha bisogno
di diventare ricercatore e ricercatrice.
Deve abbandonare quel ruolo
di sacerdote delle Sacre Scritture,
che fa conoscere le Sacre Scritture.
Deve diventare piuttosto una guida,
una guida come Virgilio lo è per Dante,
che lo aiuta nella ricerca,
però anche lo raccoglie quando sviene.
E in questo, spesso,
le insegnanti si sentono sole.
E passiamo a quello
che è il nostro quarto schema,
che è: sì, si sentono sole,
si sentono individui isolati.
Ma in realtà tutti
si sentono soli in una scuola,
ciascuno sulla propria barricata:
"Ah, io sono il genitore,
tu fai il tuo mestiere".
Oppure, all'interno di professionalità,
quando va bene "Io faccio il mio lavoro,
tu fa il tuo lavoro".
Ognuno come un individuo isolato,
a difendere una sorta di avamposto.
Eh, ma anche qui non è sempre così.
Ci sono luoghi dove questo,
invece, è possibile,
dove si respira tutta un'altra atmosfera.
E noi, la nostra quarta chiave
la chiamiamo "patti
educativi di comunità".
Chi già è un po' dentro la scuola
sa che sono stati già introdotti
durante la pandemia:
adesso è necessario
che diventino reali, concreti,
e non soltanto formali.
E necessario che ci si metta
intorno a un tavolo tutti:
non solo docenti e genitori
ma anche, ovviamente,
il dirigente, il terzo settore,
gli assistenti sociosanitari,
psicologi, pedagogisti,
gli alunni e le alunne,
tutte intorno a un tavolo.
Non per convenienza:
ciò che mettiamo intorno,
in mezzo a quel tavolo, è fondamentale.
Se noi mettiamo soltanto
il leggere e lo scrivere,
non è la stessa cosa del mettere, invece,
l'ascolto delle giovani persone,
il dialogo, la cooperazione,
la felicità dei bambini e delle bambine,
e anche di tutte le persone
che sono a scuola.
E inoltre, sono vari livelli.
Sono necessari patti
per la comunità classe,
per la comunità scolastica,
per la comunità territoriale.
E una delle cose necessarie
sono le relazioni.
E qui veniamo a quello
che è il nostro quinto schema.
Le relazioni sono complesse,
in genere sono:
"Io ho ragione e tu hai torto,
io valgo più di te."
E questa modalità potremmo chiamarla
"Modalità Tennis",
una modalità che, come dire,
cerca di fare punto continuamente.
E invece avremmo bisogno
di relazioni generative, non violente.
Che cosa vuol dire?
Se prima abbiamo parlato
di "modalità tennis",
qui potremmo parlare
di "modalità racchettoni",
cioè tenere in campo
la palla il più possibile,
e l'altro non è un nemico da abbattere,
ma un compagno con cui giocare.
Più manteniamo la palla,
e più ci divertiamo.
Il modello della prevaricazione
è molto complesso
da superare e da sconfinare,
perché è un modello culturale
che ci portiamo avanti da millenni,
per cui è davvero, davvero difficile.
Ma in alcune scuole si sta provando,
utilizzando tempi e spazi per l'ascolto,
per la conoscenza reciproca,
la formazione di tutta la comunità,
di tutte le persone di cui parlavamo prima
intorno al tavolo,
cercando di fare una formazione
dove si parli di dialogo,
dove si parli di trasformazione
dei conflitti, dove si parli di empatia,
dove si riesca a superare
quell'analfabetismo relazionale
che noi abbiamo.
Noi siamo bravissimi in tecnologia,
siamo migliorati tantissimo;
e invece, nell'aspetto relazionale
siamo ancora molto primitivi.
E a proposito di tecnologie,
passiamo a quella che è
la nostra ultima chiave:
il digitale.
Online e offline, ormai,
non si possono più contrapporre.
Non è possibile
che a scuola abbiamo l'offline
e fuori siamo tutti online,
oppure che ci immaginiamo proprio
che esistano queste due differenze.
Io oggi sono qui, in presenza;
ma magari qualcuno
sta googlando chi sono io,
che cos'è "la scuola sconfinata",
che è un libro in digitale,
ma anche un libro di carta.
Oggi sono qui, poi sarò su un video.
Quindi non c'è più questa differenza,
né è la tecnologia
tutte le soluzioni o tutti i mali.
Oggi abbiamo bisogno di parlare
di quello che si chiama
"cittadinanza digitale",
cioè un digitale democratico.
"Digitale democratico" significa
che più che avere anche tutti i mezzi
per poter raggiungere i mezzi
per diminuire il divario -
parlo di mezzi tecnici -
abbiamo bisogno di formarci
su come usare la tecnologia
se vogliamo davvero colmare
il divario che sta crescendo,
sempre più un nuovo divario.
E inoltre, per esempio,
utilizzare piattaforme gratuite,
anziché le piattaforme
delle multinazionali.
Ecco, questa era l'ultima nostra chiave.
Sono sei chiavi per sconfinare,
per una scuola sconfinata;
e sono sei chiavi
tutte ugualmente importanti
e tutte interdipendenti
come, diciamo, un organismo,
un organismo vivente.
E allora, forse adesso dovremmo chiederci:
ma perché vogliamo cambiare la scuola?
O meglio: il perché magari lo sappiamo,
ma perché in questa direzione?
Perché nella direzione
della scuola sconfinata?
Innanzitutto, perché i ragazzi
e le ragazze stanno male.
È urgente, la scuola sconfinata:
e noi, come adulti, abbiamo
il dovere di occuparcene.
E poi, perché abbiamo bisogno
di fare un salto, e un salto importante:
abbiamo bisogno di fare un salto
sul nostro sistema patriarcale,
prevaricante, dominante,
vendicativo, violento, punitivo.
Dobbiamo fare un salto
verso l'abbandono del pensiero dicotomico,
del giusto / sbagliato,
bianco / nero, premio / punizione.
Ma anche scuola / fuori scuola,
maschio / femmina -
uguali / diversi,
perché siamo uguali e diversi.
Abbiamo bisogno
di uscire dall'individualismo
per riconoscerci in un noi,
in un'unica nazione umana universale.
Abbiamo bisogno di cooperare
non solo per lavorare meglio:
sì, anche per lavorare meglio,
ma per poter costruire,
tentare di costruire
una cultura di non violenza
che oggi abbiamo visto tanto necessaria
per il proseguimento della nostra specie.
E all'interno di tutto questo,
la scuola è cruciale in questi argomenti.
Per questo abbiamo bisogno
di una scuola sconfinata.
Che cosa possiamo fare?
Possiamo immaginarci,
ciascuno di noi può immaginarsi,
una scuola sconfinata,
perché ciascuno deve fare
la propria parte.
E in fondo, c'è bisogno di alcune leggi:
ma anche le leggi
sono fatte dalle persone.
Per cui possiamo provare
a chiudere gli occhi,
immaginarci una scuola sconfinata
nel nostro quartiere,
perché il cambiamento -
la scuola sconfinata parte
da questa piccola rivoluzione,
quando cambiamo proprio l'immaginazione,
quando diciamo "scuola".
E con questo, abbiamo terminato
il nostro viaggio.
Per ora, per ora!
(Applausi)